[Music]  special guest in the audience tonight  legendary record executive mr clyde  davis  my voice is gone what you start the show  tonight no talking back i'm your mother  [Applause]  there's a boy  i know  he's a wanna dreamer what's your name  again  whitney elizabeth houston  wake up it's on it's unlisted  he really loves me  my dream  sing what i want to sing be how i want  to be  as big an audience as i can  uh common criticism of you your music  isn't black enough  look i don't know how to sing black and  i don't know how to sing white either  i know how to sing  i might have just heard the greatest  voice of her generation  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  ah  maybe maybe it's got to have a hook a  hook yeah  i'll give it a hook  [Music]  you